so this is a talking video
about uh what i've been
giving on youtube channels
but it's really for those of you who are
contributors
to know more and more detail
the things that i give to you
i only give to you the importance of
knowledge we
what do they say we can't buy knowledge
well you have to gain it individually
but you can listen to my words but
whether you
put them into your mind is entirely up
to you
the techniques are there for us to train
and most people are fulfilled with the
enjoyment
of the techniques you perhaps prefer
jolt again
came to joe or perhaps you just like
taijitsu
if we had to line people up
out of 100 more would like taijitsu than
they like the weapons
and yet they don't realize the weapons
is to enhance their taijitsu so we need
to do as much weapons as we possibly can
but we mustn't just be looking at the
pleasure of the weapons
and the technical aspects we must look
at
how our body is moving how it twists
turns how it coordinates
so the coordination is what i'd like to
talk about here
coordination of thinking
i many years ago decided that i had to
put a stake in because
aikido is so complicated i'm trying to
think of everything
and i need to make some kind of sense
you know like a
one brick will not build a house but
many bricks
well where
do you start you'd start by choosing
if you've ever thought about building a
house
then that's a start
but like myself i've built four now
two of them have been of brick and what
you do is you go to the
builders merchants and you choose a
brick
and there's so many bricks you wouldn't
believe soft hard colored
and it goes on and on and then once you
finish with all the bricks that have
been made
made in the uk you then go on to what
the european brick
manufacturers provide
just the same as aikido all the teachers
telling you
how to do aikido what to do
what's the best way of doing it
so you finally narrow it down to a few
bricks you might take the bricks home
put them out straight away
you'll wonder why you've chosen one if
you've got four bricks you might think
straight away oh
why did i choose that one that
definitely
yeah is it in a better light that you've
seen it
so aikido is no different than choosing
the bricks for your house
but one is no good but when you narrow
it down
and i narrowed down sight of scentsy
he made the most sense all the time
i never got confused by him because he
was quite a simple man and he spoke my
language
simple language and i'm trying to give
you
the same simple answers
and this is what you're hopefully
getting out of these films
detail points you're getting bricks
to choose different bricks but you need
to
be the brick layer at some stage and
start to lay them yourself
and lay them in what order you want
you may not know this either but you can
get a book
on different designs of how the bricks
are laid
there's multiple different designs
even though the brick is the same size
as an end
a top or bottom you know a certain
length
for the normal bricks
so what i decided was i must think about
what cytosensei said and i must
try to adopt them
and not just adopt them in words and
thoughts but i must adopt them
100 but until i can do so
i must know that i have a weakness
my weakness is believing
he would often say when doing a
demonstration from
shomonucci he would step to the side
what does all on its own means police
but he would then get the translator to
say
please go past
so when i thought about this
i thought well it's okay just
you know it's like having one brick
please go pass
but what do i do then you know i want to
do a technique on this person
i don't want to just please go past
doors or doors or
i mean that's not any fun is it
but once you start building the wall of
thoughts
you realize i'm not very flexible am i
people don't want to do the exercises
but you need flexibility but flexibility
of mind as well as body
so i do yoga i try to keep
as flexible as i can even though my body
doesn't stay flexible
they say in aikido breathing is very
important
but if you training hard your breathing
will increase your lungs will get better
your pulse will drop because you're
getting fitter
that can be natural you don't really
have to train
how to breathe but if it pleases you
and you want to breathe with the
refinement
you can study qigong
and so i studied qigong tai chi
chico now studying tai chi gave me the
understanding
that i was perhaps doing an iccio
and all the other techniques different
each time i wasn't they didn't have the
exact
same like stamping out on a
sausage factory every sausage is the
same
they were differing
so i then realized that when
you say please go past
you must make the technique
as easy as possible for yourself
but without disturbing your ook is
passing you
this led me on to thinking about
shia nagi and how in shia and aggie
we step across that line on an emote
negative we step across the line
and really you're blocking them but
if you think about them coming towards
you and you do the shia nagi
in a flowing way where as they come
forward you move forward with them
but you're carrying out the act of shia
nagi
then you are saying mentally
please go past because you're not
restricting or in it inhibiting
the flow of that technique you don't
stop them as soon as they get there this
is in kindergarten
you don't stop them as soon as they get
there perform
the sheer nagi the next thing you throw
them to the floor
you blend and you
carry that lens slowly forward as you do
the sheer nagging
you can do this on the mote
it's easy on the url shenagi because
even though you're going on the back of
them
you actually don't have to go around the
back you can
turn but go forward on your turn
if you try enough times you'll
understand what i mean
now in kihon what is solid static
we're learning to move the unimovable
so this is going to build up your
confidence your stability
your power the technique
if you can have that in mind that
please go past what happens is
you use your flexible body
to allow non-resistance
non-resistance in yourself
non-resistance in the technique
so you try to keep expanding from you
and i will when we get back to training
on the mat i will
demonstrate these at the moment
their seeds for you to think about
okay so find something
that you keep hearing but you don't
understand it find your first brick
find realize that to do o senses aikido
you must not inhibit the person
when they're coming towards you in any
way
yet you have to perform a technique the
technique must be done
in the smoothest way the only problem is
your body may get in their way
and you may be the cause of this
so flowing aikido isn't just
a way of allowing them to pass you
it's an attitude of mind a flow
of non-resistance within yourself as
well as them
i hope this is partly making sense
and i'll go into it more
as the time goes by
thank you for listening and thank you
for taking part
in my patreon site